and when you meet someone for the first
time what's the first thing you look at
first couple seconds of meeting up their
face survey that's their eyes let's be
honest here
that's the eyes their style the eyes
what is it about the eyes ah whether
they're alive or not
oh that's first couple seconds your eyes
their eyes their eyes their iron so it
seems like most people claim to look at
eyes first I don't know if I believe
that we're gonna go back to the office
test it out see if it's true all right
now we're back at the office
I'm gonna grab Jessica and we're gonna
get going on an experiment to find out
what people actually do look at when
they first meet someone so step one we
need to hire some humans and shoot
footage of them walking talking looking
into the camera and getting undressed
you know human stuff then we set up
emotions and eye tracking software and
bring in our co-workers to check out the
footage face looking at their faces as
they watch this odd video we will record
every movement of their eyes when we
watch the analysis back in search of
patterns we found some unexpected
results the first was that ladies and
dudes seemed to check out foods the same
amount yeah dudes thought they'd
probably glanced at breasts at least
with women I'm definitely looking at you
know like yeah breasts and she's wearing
an open shirt where you [ __ ] like the
deep V but women dig boobs too oh wow
that is a deeply cut shirt and the
second super surprising result was that
even when all the accessories boob dicks
and all the distractions they're all in
the frame we still look at faces the
most and not just eyes as many thought
but the whole face but why do we do this
is it to be polite is it because eyes
are the window to the soul nope research
actually hypothesizes that we look at
faces first because we're programmed to
find faces in fact look what happens
when we show people this picture of
pasta we find the face even in this
inanimate picture and this picture and
this one too this is because as social
creatures our ability to quickly find a
face and determine if it was friendly or
not kept our ancestors alive today those
same skills help us navigate our complex
social world of group hangs and tinder
dates hmm
so people were kind of right we do look
at eyes first but it's only because
we're hardwired to find and interpret
faces that's some cool science yeah yeah
yeah cool science